yeah immediately i was like oh yeah this
is this is gonna be great because it's
just like you understood my my jokes
yes it's like humor you know what i'm
saying same the references
[Music]
i
like any fan got to kind of enjoy it
from a fan's perspective because i
didn't get to see much of what they shot
so
i can say i too was surprised by you
know like i was stressed out like anyone
else i mean i'd read the books but it's
one thing to read the book and then to
also experience it this way so i i was
blown away i was totally blown away
well definitely that it's uh
it's a marathon and not a sprint on a
movie like this i had never worked on
something this long or as you put it
physically demanding
with the still suit just just the
requirements that i had too just to be
fighting in scenes or running across the
desert obviously there's way harder jobs
out there but
uh
it was definitely one of the bigger
challenges physically i've been on and
mentally when you're surrounded by great
cast mates and a great director and
people that are confident and assured
then it's easier to get through too and
now that we're doing press it's a lot of
fun too cause you all get along that's
true
i would say uh
for me i think it's like about
trying like trying to carve out the time
to find some consistencies
and whether that be small or big i know
it sounds really corny whether that is
like
um you know making your coffee in the
morning or you know if you have the
means to see your therapist every week
or whatever it is just having a
consistent thing that feels like a feels
like you time i feel is something i'm
trying to get better at like i'll i'll
take some time i'll be like no i'm just
gonna paint and i spend hours doing it
whether i like it or not is not the
point but i'm like you know what i'm
going to sit here i'm going to paint and
have time just to myself i'm not on my
phone i'm just you know whatever
uh so i think those things are are
important um and then reaching out to
people right you know like having a
support system talking to people who um
helped get you to do it
that was perfectly safe all right
consistency that's really that's really
well it's inconsistencies and i feel
like you're really good at that
yeah i try yeah
well i don't know about me but i can say
i'll cover your ears now yeah yeah yeah
no just it's i'm really impressed that
zenday has been working all these
interviews were just blowing smoke
but uh
it's just amazing to actually just put
consistencies and
this is a crazy business so
zane is really one of the most grounded
people i know doing this and
it's a reassuring to have a friend like
that because uh
it could be an absolute circuit so like
yeah you know yeah
i would agree i was like i've got
nothing
no because sometimes you feel like
you're you're you know in this in this
industry you're floating right and you
you need those
those um
those people that feel like i don't know
like uh
some stability or like uh
i'm trying to
figure out a better like uh metaphor for
this right but you know you're like in
the middle of the scene you're looking
for the island and i think when you find
true true friendships and people who
enjoy doing what you do um but you also
admire i think i admire timothy's work
and and being able to watch him work
in real life
is like another special experience so i
think being able to
communicate and talk to someone about a
very specific
experience in life that a lot of a lot
of people maybe haven't experience or
don't quite understand it's uh that you
need that you know it makes you feel a
little less alone like you're not in
this by yourself right you're not
floating there is other people that you
can you know grab onto and and um and
help you through it so um you need that
you need people to learn from
oh for sure
i think so yeah well i think a lot of
uh what are they called the uh day day
of stars
one of many
i think the first moment like because i
saw zendayo when she got to jordan and
without being aegis there was no one
within
[ __ ] 15 years ago
no so it was just a great that's that's
also true for paul yeah yeah yeah he's
going through tough yeah like a really
tough uh circumstance where he has to be
a leader amongst adults at too young and
age but just when zendaya got there the
energy she brought to jordan we weren't
uh
you know part of the world that i'd
never been in before and uh we just had
so much fun and she brought a great
energy and i think we have a similar
we can tap into a similar chaos and
that's yeah
that's important that's important that's
important uh
yeah i think yeah immediately i was like
oh yeah this is this is gonna be great
because it's just like you understood my
my jokes
yes it's like humor you know what i'm
saying insane the references if you if
you get my references that's a very
important thing so i was like oh yeah
we're good
you ever watch like um dragon's tales
dragon tails
yes that's
[Laughter]
i think when you're growing up you
always feel out of your body you're
looking in the mirror to confirm your
identity or to shred your identity or to
hate yourself and you know
i think that's probably the most
challenging period in life when you're
truly a fish out of water but the
brilliance in that too is that you can
kind of search for your identity search
for what makes you feel grounded find
the good people in your life those
non-toxic ass people
and
and i think that's uh yeah that's what i
would say
i would say honestly every project that
you that you kind of take on there's a
bit of fear there because there's no
guarantee that anything will work out
the way you see it in your head or that
you hope it will
um
and so everything kind of sometimes
feels like a little bit of a leap of
faith you know and and you all you can
really control is your work all you can
do is do your best job
and and work your very hardest and hope
that something good comes of it you know
so i would say it kind of happens uh
every time you kind of tackle a new
project you know you're just like
okay here we go you know and um
so yeah i don't know i think i feel that
fear every time which i think is a good
thing you know it's good to feel that
feeling i hope i hope that i i feel that
every time even when i get you know get
older and do other things you know i
think that's good it's motivating
you try to be in the circumstance your
character try to be in the circumstance
of the movie for me playing paul trades
in this one any sort of tension or
anything you're alluding to would help
the character and help the arc and the
story but then you try to like uh you
know distract yourself from the
seriousness of that or something or the
self-seriousness or the pressure or
outside opinions whatever and it's
you're able to do that really most
successfully when you're
when you're you know uh colleagues
basically are are uh
are fighting that same fight in some way
i i take this pressure over you know
over there other pressures i felt in
life before i had a career
i think i found my power when i'm
working
uh which
i've learned over this you know pandemic
is maybe a good and a bad thing you have
to find
life and power in other ways and not
just your work zendaya
you know um
yeah which i'm learning about uh but you
know i definitely i feel empowered when
i when i
when i work because i really i really
love my job and i feel incredibly
grateful to be doing what i love for a
living um and um
i so every day that i that i wake up and
i get to do this i just um this is just
a massive sense of gratitude um for the
fact that this is this is my job but um
again with that that it feels empowering
because i feel like i'm in my element
like i don't know
you know when you're just on set and it
just you just feel like yeah this is my
place like this is my home